hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
we have some pretty nice information to
talk about with some new content but
also some pretty sad news but it's also
pretty helpful as well so a huge mixed
bag of emotions today but as you could
tell from the title of course but as a
lot as like to be if you do enjoy
subscriber free new I covered the
informational side of for honor and with
that let's get started with today's
video so to get the really quick things
out of the way we have a new 5,000 steel
effect called the messenger wings this
is going to be obviously for the effects
tab of the game and it looks pretty cool
the wings aren't extremely huge they're
very transparent though but I think they
look pretty cool and you can pick that
up in the shop for 5,000 steal some
awesome new content there and something
extremely huge is that there's going to
be double xp starting April 9th which is
today so at the time you're seeing this
video it is out and it isn't just a
weekend not one week but two weeks of
double xp until April 23rd that is a
huge amount of time for double xp so if
you have a new character and let's be
honest we pretty much are doing jack
[ __ ] now thanks to this all the stuff
going on recently so two weeks of
grinding characters yes please and then
lastly this is a message to our
community from the developers of for
honor and I'm going to read this out to
you guys it's as first and foremost we
hope that everyone is doing well and is
safe at home during these times on our
side the team is still hard at work to
keep foreign or fully operational even
though we are doing some from home we
are proud of how quickly everyone on the
400 development team has adapted to the
situation however even with all efforts
during these times the disruption over
the past weeks is having an impact on
our ability to deliver our new term
content updates for this reason we have
made the decision to delay the release
of a year for season 2 to June 11th 2020
we know that news is disappointing and
we're all excited to be able to show you
what was coming in for honor for the
upcoming season however we're confident
this was the right decision for us to be
able to launch the content as we
intended on a positive note the team is
currently working on a plan to be able
to bring back fan favorite activities to
compensate for this delay those
activities will be available in the may
roadmap which will showcase a little bit
later we want to thank you for your
continued passion and support and stay
safe and that was where the mixed bag of
emotions comes in so on the negative we
aren't getting season two for actually
pretty much two months could is April
9th and that comes out in June 11th so
we have pretty much two months of the
same season which also you haven't done
the battle past that's two more months
of completing this season won a battle
pass that's gonna be a little bit of a
problem but on the plus side we are at
least getting some stuff coming in the
game now the April roadmap or whatever
they had planned for April is still
going to stay it's the stuff in May
that's going to be a little bit tricky
because that's the new stuff they're
adding as they plan to release this in
May as you know that's what the timer of
the battle past being like 30 days or so
it was the this new season was supposed
to launch a very early in May and now
it's launching very early in June now my
idea and a lot of other I'd people's
ideas for this new fan favorite activity
the first thing that clicks into mind is
the season 5 event of polygons legacy
honestly it would make the entire thing
better I would wait months for a new
season to come out if he just gave me
two or three weeks of a polygons legacy
but just because it's considered a
fan-favorite activity doesn't mean it
has to be an event it could be a new
game-mode you know care cell death can
come back ice brawler's can come back so
many different things have happened over
the course of this four year three year
game that there's so many things they
could add back at any point possible
they could make they could make the
rabbits come back but for like two
straight weeks if they wanted to so they
have loads of different options and
maybe even some actual new original
options to bring for may so I'm excited
to see what they're coming out with
obviously we don't have an April roadmap
just yet at the time that I'm making
this video although maybe in a couple
hours they might release one or maybe
next week but we'll have to see
top of that there's also going to be the
new executions that are coming out
probably within the next two to three
weeks unless that was going to be the
stuff that's delay to which in that case
will not happen until May but once again
we have to check and figure everything
out really quickly when the April
roadmap drops yeah that's pretty much
going to be today's video guys like to
be if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I covered the informational side of
for honor and with that yeah hopefully
you enjoyed this mixed bag of emotions
and all this stuff going on I think even
though it's you know it sounds bad I'm
pretty hopeful I mean I'm always down to
get new content and if that means I have
to wait a couple months to get the new
season that's totally fine alright the
hero isn't going to keep me the new hero
the new battle pass is going to keep me
entertained for two months or isn't
going to you know spark my joy back in
the game it's just gonna be new content
that they release or even bringing back
old stuff so I'm totally okay with
what's going to be happening yeah I've
already done the outro so I'm just gonna
end here take care guys have a great
stir day peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]